nous accueillons aujourd'hui madame
béatrice angrand qui est présidente de
l' agence du service civique
je précise que eu l'occasion déjà de
recevoir dans le cadre de la mission sur
la vie étudiante que préside pierre
auzias c'est pour lequel je suis
rapporteur on a eu l'occasion de vous
auditionné on avait trouvé votre
intervention particulièrement éclairante
sur l'organisation du service civique et
les enjeux qui sont derrière le service
civique
on sait que c'est une organisation qui
est aujourd'hui connue et reconnue par
les jeunes qui a fait ses preuves
alors qu'en 2010 année de sa création
6000 d'entre eux avaient effectué une
mission l'objectif est de 145 mille
volontaires en 2020 avant là pour délit
de duke au vide
le service civique est d'une certaine
manière plébiscitée chaque année et vous
allez bien sûr nous expliquer tout ça le
nombre de demandes est largement
supérieur au nombre de places
disponibles
tous ici je crois pouvoir le dire parce
qu'on a déjà eu l'occasion à plusieurs
reprises notamment lors de des
discussions sur le plf tous ici nous
sommes convaincus de l'utilité de ce
dispositif
nous avons d'ailleurs souligné il ya
tout juste un an l'occasion de la remise
des conclusions du groupe de travail
piloté par notre collègue jacques
bernard magner sur les conséquences de
l'aco vide sur les secteurs de la
jeunesse et de la vie associative les
questions de mes collègues sont
certainement nombreuses je concentrerai
les miennes sur le rôle que le service
civique est amené à jouer dans le cadre
du plan de relance puisque dans son
discours du 14 juillet dernier le
président de la république a annoncé la
création de cent mille missions de
services publics supplémentaires dans le
cadre du plan un jeune une solution dont
20000 dès 2020 et 80000 en 2021
rapporté au nombre habituel de mission à
savoir 145000 le défi à relever est
importante on est sur une progression de
69 % du nombre de services physiques
pour wii vous nous faire un premier
bilan de la mise en oeuvre des ses
objectifs dans le cadre du plan de
relance
avez vous constaté une évolution des
profils des jeunes qui candidatent en
et 2021 par rapport aux années
précédentes est ce qu'il ya des
difficultés à trouver cent mille jeunes
supplémentaires
d'une certaine manière quel est le
potentiel qu'on peut évaluer avec ce
cette augmentation significative du
nombre de service civique est ce que
vous avez aussi on sait qu'il a fallu
mobiliser des partenaires pour trouver
ces jeunes est ce que vous avez une
typologie des nouveaux partenaires voilà
quelques unes des questions que voulez
vous poser après votre intervention
liminaire entre dix et quinze minutes je
passerai la parole à mes collègues en
commençant bien sûr par jacques bernard
magner rapporteur des crédits
budgétaires qui aura certainement un
certain nombre de questions à vous poser
et puis les autres sénateurs et
sénatrices également madame la
présidente si vous voulez intervenir en
propos liminaire le président messieurs
les sénateurs vous remercie beaucoup de
cette sollicitation c'est évidemment
toujours un honneur et un plaisir de
partager mon enthousiasme pour pour le
service civique pour sept grandes
politiques publiques qui a fêté ses 11
ans en mars dernier je suis accompagné
ce matin d'elodie morival qui est
secrétaire général de l' agence du
service civique depuis près de deux ans
près de deux ans maintenant alors
peut-être en propos liminaire
[Musique]
je vais être généraliste en essayant
même de répondre aux questions qui m'ont
été adressées dans le questionnaire et
puis bien sûr je serai très heureuse
ensuite nous serons ensuite très
heureuse de de répondre à vos
interrogations
alors cela fait maintenant près d'un an
que le président de la république a
annoncé une augmentation
fortin des missions de service civique
puisqu'il a annoncé cela le 14 juillet
2020 il a annoncé en disant nous avons
décidé d'augmenter de le service civique
de cent mille médecins supplémentaires
parce que le service civique fonctionne
donc là on l'a on l'a pris comme d'abord
comme une reconnaissance du travail
accompli par l' agence par les délégués
territoriaux par tout l'écosystème du
service civique je reviendrai donc une
reconnaissance et puis aussi pas une
injonction à faire mieux non seulement
sur le plan quête quantitatif mais aussi
sur cette question de si le service
civique fonctionne qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il est un tremplin
pour les jeunes qui leur est utile que
c'est pas simplement huit mois passés à
rendre service mais qui évidemment ça
les aide les aident à rebondir donc
c'était ça pour nous la question depuis
un an c'est comment on s'organise
comment on met en branle écosystèmes
pour permettre à toujours plus de jeunes
d'entrer en service civique dans le
respect des fondamentaux du service
civique c'est à dire principalement la
non substitution à l'emploi de veiller à
ce que les jeunes agissent toujours en
complémentarité de l'action des agents
publics s'ils sont en mission dans les
services de l'état où les établissements
qui dépendent d'eux les collectivités
territoriales en complément des salariés
ou des bénévoles des associations donc
ça ça a été vraiment notre boussole
parfois on est confronté à cette
contradiction sur de la quantité versus
la qualité mais on essaie vraiment de
tenir bon parce que justement le ça
fonctionne ça dépend pas ça dépend de la
quantité mais cela dépend beaucoup
beaucoup de la qualité donc ce qu'on a
ce qu'on a mis en place déjà de
s'assurer que nous avons les moyens nous
avions les moyens budgétaires
pour accompagner cette montée en charge
de qui s'est ensuite précisé après les
annonces du président ça s'est précisé
dans des relations avec le gouvernement
le plan et le plan de relance donc ce
qui était décidée c'est effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président 20000 mission supplémentaire
jusqu'à la fin 2020 et on a terminé 2020
on y reviendra très 19000 mission
supplémentaire donc vraiment très proche
de la cible et je pense que regard des
conditions dans lesquelles nous avons
travaillé et les conditions évidemment
extérieurs c'est à dire sanitaire c'est
un très bon résultat donc garantir les
moyens il nous fallait des moyens
complémentaires pour absorber ces vingt
mille missions supplémentaires et
ensuite on a aussi bien sûr travailler
pour avoir les moyens supplémentaires
pour absorber 80 missions
supplémentaires en 2021 dans le même
temps pour être tout à fait
transparentes
on a négocié pour pouvoir obtenir des
agents enfin des de tp à un relèvement
du tableau des emplois qui nous a été
avec accordés pour 15 tp ce qui n'est
que justice
en réalité parce qu'en fait bon c'était
un relèvement du tableau des emplois qui
auraient dû avoir déjà avant puisque ça
faisait des années que nous absorbons
entre guillemets pour se terminer pas
connotée 1 mais il est juste technique
une montée en charge importante plus ou
moins forte selon les années mais en
tout cas toujours à la hausse et que de
tableau des emplois avaient été relevés
pour la dernière fois en 2015 donc voilà
l'organisation d'abord s'assurer des
moyens financiers des moyens humains
ensuite travaillé avec l'écosystème du
service civique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que bien sûr sous la houlette de notre
tutelle à djerba et de la secrétaire
d'état qui a pris ses fonctions donc en
juillet succession gabriela talent on a
regardé quels sont les priorités
thématiques quels sont les et nouveaux
espaces de développement possible et
quelles peuvent être les outils les
leviers qui peuvent nous aider à réussir
à la fois la quantité la qualité comme
je le disais tout à l'heure donc on a
donc développé en place une stratégie en
trois axes le premier c'est de nouvelles
thématiques ou des thématiques renforcer
le plus souvent c'était des domaines des
champs d'action qui se sont accrues ou
révélé pendant la crise
j'en citerai quelques-uns bien
sur la lutte contre l'isolément des
personnes âgées l'accompagnement des
personnes fragiles isolées en difficulté
comme les personnes en situation de
handicap
le soutien puisque on est ici à la
commission culture éducation il faut que
vous sachiez que la question évidemment
de la continuité pédagogique nous a
beaucoup occupé avec des partenaires
comme la fève animafac est haute
bien sûr le programme de devoirs faits
du ministre jean michel blanquer
donc ça c'était une deuxième thématique
forte
la troisième ça a été bien sûr la santé
de regarder comment on pouvait déployer
enfin invité les organismes d'accueil à
déployer des missions de service civique
dans ce champ là sans évidemment que les
les jeunes se substituent à des
infirmiers à des aides soignantes ou à
des agents publics donc on a assez bien
réussi avec des partenaires comme la
croix rouge ou ou l'ap-hp 1 sur des
missions vraiment de jeunes qui étaient
en support dans les centres de
vaccination ou des choses très
intéressantes de jeunes parfois sous la
houlette des préfectures qui sont allés
dans qui vont d'ailleurs ça continue
dans les quartiers à en direction des
publics non non francophones pour faire
la pédagogie d'abord de l'actualité des
gestes barrières donc des choses
vraiment vraiment intéressant donc ça
c'était le troisième domaine
et puis ensuite des choses plus
classiques mais nous avons renforcé
comme le développement durable émission
autour du développement durable et
l'égalité femmes-hommes parce que vous
avez vu que depuis mars 2020 et les
violences faites aux femmes a augmenté
de 30%
on a par exemple travaillé avec les caf
ou avec des associations comme la
fondation des femmes pour développer
plus de missions sur sur ce champ là
voilà de manière très très général
la stratégie donc nouvelles thématiques
ou thématiques renforcées ensuite
nouveaux espaces de développement donc
là on a regardé ce qui existait déjà
ce qui pouvait les les organisent les
espaces qui pouvait accueillir plus de
jeunes on a identifié trois pistes la
première c'est la vie associative pour
que certaines associations accueillent
plus de jeunes ça a été le cas des
grandes associations comme unis site
et où la ligue de l'enseignement et que
des nouvelles associations qui ne
seraient pas encore agréé service
civique puisse le devenir on a vite
remarqué de vue en fait que la vie
associative et est à saturation
de toutes façons notamment dans le sport
assez empêché dans ses activités donc
quand même arrivé en tout cas maintenant
ça reprend on y reviendra je reviens
deviendrait vite ans et sur les chiffres
mais on voit bien en tout cas jusqu'à
jusqu'à peu près mais ou même même début
juin 2021 que l'espagne la vie
associative était assez limité
proportionnellement dans sa capacité à
accueillir plus de gènes mais quand même
essayé avec avec certains succès
deuxième espace de développement c'est
qu'on a travaillé là en interministériel
piloté par par matignon pour avait on a
travaillé avec bien sûr les grands
services publics et les établissements
qui dépendent d'eux pour augmenter le
nombre de missions dans les services de
l'état principalement le ministère de
l'intérieur avec des missions assez
intéressante qu'ils ont mis en place sur
la relation policiers jeunesse de choses
quand même vraiment intéressante avec le
ministère de la condition écologique et
solidaire bien sûr le ministère de
l'éducation nationale dont les missions
ont fortement augmenté cette année de 20
mille vingt mille postes en tout cas
20000 mission à quelques grands
ministères comme ça il a été fixé à
l'état pour parler de manière générale
la cible de plus 34 missions 1 par
rapport aux années précédentes et
troisième espace de développement
ce sont les collectivités territoriales
qui jusqu'à cette année en fait ne
représentaient que 6 % des organismes
d'accueil et 14 % des jeunes parfois oui
c'est ça et dans lesquels on enregistre
une très forte croissance à peu près la
date c'est presque 50 % d'augmentation
des missions dans les collectivités
territoriales principalement les
communes et les oeufs cpi mais on
observe aussi des choses intéressantes
dans les départements
un petit peu un petit peu les les
régions et troisième axe de la stratégie
c'était les outils alors des outils
c'est la communication l'information le
renforcement de la formation des tuteurs
c'est aussi des leviers avec dédé voilà
auquel on a donné des terme un peu
barbare comme les pôles d'appui
l'intermédiation ça existait déjà avant
tout un peintre nm détail devrait pas
être long en introduction mais voilà
tout ce qui peut nous aider
bien sûr à atteindre à atteindre ce qui
est pour nous la double cible la
quantité et la qualité voilà de manière
générale peut-être je vous donne les
chiffres pour finir et puis on passera
la partie questions donc vous rappeler
que le service civique a bénéficié à
près de 530 plus tenons à plus de 530
mille volontaires depuis sa création
je trouve que c'est un voilà un résultat
formidable qui nous permet dire qu'on
vérifie si en france d'une cohorte de
jeunes qui grâce au service civique a
façonné son à façonner pays a pu
développer son pouvoir d'agir et c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet sur lequel on
travaille on lancera des choses à la
rentrée pour mieux animer cette
communauté de cette communauté des
volontaires c'est un point qui a été un
peu négligé depuis la création il nous
semble vraiment important d'entretenir
le sentiment d'appartenance ce sentiment
collectif et il me semble que ce qu'on a
vu pendant le premier le confinement un
peu moins dans le deuxième mais c'était
quand même assez assez frappant ces
milliers de jeunes engagés qui sont
allés faire des courses pour les
personnes âgées conduire des personnes
malades dans des personnes sans abri
dans des centres d'hébergement
tous ces jeunes qui auront rendu service
beaucoup étaient en service civique
empêché d'accomplir leur mission ils se
sont tout de suite transformé en
bénévoles soit grâce à leurs réserves
civique soit de manière tout à fait
spontané donc pour moi le lien est clair
dans la société dans cette jeunesse
engagée française entre tous qui est
tous ces volontaires et involontaires
c'est un écosystème il influence ses
amis ses parents son école etc
pour moi il ya un lien direct entre la
réussite du service civique et cette
jeunesse française très engagés dont on
a vu dont on l'a vu donner le meilleur
d'elle-même pendant les les deux
confinement donc je reviens à mes
chiffres 500 plus de 530 mille
volontaires depuis 2010 les cibles qui a
été fixé à 245 mines d'ici la fin de
l'année 2021 pour une cible initiale de
145000 au budget au budget initial 2020
l'année 2020 a permis l'engagement de
130 me 131 1700 volontaires
donc évidemment pour des raisons
évidentes en deçà de la cible mais sans
verser dans l'autosatisfaction je crois
que terminer l'année 2020 à 131 1700
volontaires c'est compte tenu du
contexte c'est vraiment un très très bon
résultat nous avons évidemment connu une
baisse très forte des entrées en mission
entre le mars et juillet et puis ensuite
une reprise très importantes à la
rentrée 2 à la rentrée de septembre
les dix neuf mille entrées en mission à
l'automne 2020 dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure qui n'ont malheureusement pas
pu évidemment est un résultat très fort
mais qui n'ont pas pu compenser la entre
guillemets la perte des mois de de
confinement alors aujourd'hui peut-être
elodie pour pour qu'on fasse un peu à
deux voix peut-être sur les résultats là
juste de janvier à de janvier à juin et
puis on passera aux questions ensuite
je vais compléter en effet sur les
chiffres à date aussi peut-être pour
préciser sur l'objectif qui nous a été
fixé sur les 245 milles quand vous
parliez monsieur sénateurs d'une housse
justement de 60% en réalité au regard de
l'atteinte de 130000 poste 231 me poste
en 2020 on est sur une hausse de 86%
dans l'objectif est surtout dans le
service civique on distingue le stock
c'est à dire les jeunes qui sont déjà en
contrat au 1er janvier et le flux c'est
à dire les nouvelles entrées qu'on va
devoir faire en 2021 et si on se
concentre sur les nouvelles entrées
qu'on doit faire en 2021
ça représente une hausse par rapport à
2000 d'un de 150%
donc c'est vraiment une montagne à
gravir ça c'est vraiment un défi qui est
particulièrement important aujourd'hui
au 21 au 30 juin
on a pu agressant 7000 postes donc
l'agent sans fatal aux touristes des
organismes à la grée des organismes à
accueillir des jeunes en service civique
ça correspond à peu près à 50 % de
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés puisqu'on
s'est fixé un objectif d'agrément de 215
milles poste pour atteindre ces 245 me
c'est déjà un niveau qui est supérieur à
celui de l'année 2020 donc c'est une
dynamique qui est forte qui évidemment
pas de la totalité de l'objectif qu'on
s'était fixé à ce stade mais qui est
quand même particulièrement dynamique et
sur les cinq premiers mois de l'année
c'est à dire que nous on ventile aussi
notre objectif mensuellement
là on a atteint 97 % notre objectif sur
les cinq premiers mois de l'année et ce
malgré la crise sanitaire qui a aussi
parfois refroidi ou en tout cas freiner
les organismes a demandé désagréments de
postes en service civique donc on
regarde à la fois les agréments c'est à
dire ce qui est vraiment à la main de l'
agence du service civique cela là où on
pilote complètement
et puis les recrutements c'est à dire la
transformation de ces agréments en
accueille véritable par par les
organismes de jeunes en service civique
et là sur le
les agréments on a eu à peu près 25
mille recrutement au titre de l'année
2000 21 depuis depuis le 1er janvier
et là on est un taux d'atteindre notre
objectif de 61%
donc on est un peu là en dessous notre
objectif c'est à dire qu'on a un
décalage entre ce qu'on pilote
complètement ce qu'on va agréer et la
réalité du terrain les recruteurs et ça
on l'expliquent aussi parce que
justement le taux de réalisation le taux
de transformation de nos agrément en
recrutement il est en baisse par rapport
l'année 2019 et par rapport à l'année
2020 précisément pour les raisons qu'on
évoquée madame la présidente
parce qu'en fait les organismes n'ont
pas eu la possibilité de transformer ces
agréments en recrutement par exemple
parce que les salles de sport étaient
fermés parce que les salles de théâtre
été fermé parce que les festivals n'ont
pas eu lieu et c'est donc on a eu un
taux de réalisation qui aujourd'hui est
autour de 50 60 % alors que d'habitude
on a à peu près 80 9% nos agrément qui
se transforme en recrutement donc
évidemment on appris on a pris des
mesures sur lesquelles on pourra revenir
pour pour renforcer ce taux de ce taux
de réalisation mais sur ce début d'année
là c'est aussi ce qui nous freine dans
l'atteinte de nos objectifs sur la
réalisation des désagréments qu'on peut
qu'on peut délivrer les raisons évoquées
par andy murray wallon les a pas inventé
pour nous excuser de pavage dans la
cible elles sont vraiment on a fait pour
être au plus proche du terrain parce que
c'est évidemment important pour nous
qu'on touche les vrais jeunes et les
vrais associations et les vrais organise
d'accueil on a fait une campagne de
phoning excusez moi pour le terme pour
demander voilà un petit peu de manière
un peu une partie on a interrogé les
gros organiser une autre partie on a
fait des sondages seraient échantillons
leur a demandé qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi les recrutements sont
inférieurs aux objectifs
évidemment les résultats ne nous ont pas
beaucoup surpris mais en tout cas nous
on permet vraiment vérifier qu'on était
au plus juste que notre analyse était
était la bonne
le point quand même des destins ce qu'il
faut savoir pour bien interpréter le
niveau d'attentes d'atteindre
principalement des recrutements qui le
dit mais rival l'a bien expliqué
et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
du tout désespéré plutôt assez confiance
et qu'on sait que le calendrier habituel
des entrées en mission pour le service
civique
il se concentre à la rentrée septembre
octobre 70 1 traditionnellement 70 à 75
% des entrées annuelles dans le
dispositif se fait de septembre à
décembre mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'indicateur qui nous dirait que ce que
le service civique va fonctionner
différemment des autres années sur ce
point là et puis une petite précision
par rapport aux chiffres c'est que
compte ni nos systèmes d'information des
relations avec l' agence de services et
paiement il ya toujours un
un parfois deux mois de décalage entre
les chiffres dont nous disposons et et
la réalité
voilà vous m'a bien être quand même
interrogé sur les la répartition dans
les domaines donc je peux pas vous
répondre pour 2021 encore mais sur 2020
par rapport à 2010 est il ya des
inflexions mais qu'ils sont mineurs sur
les thématiques de mission donc on voit
un peu moins de mission dans ce cas et
éducation pour tous à salaire de
contredire ce que je vous disais sur la
continuité pédagogique mais bon je pense
que c'est vraiment lié à la crise
sanitaire ca augmenter de 2% sur la sur
la solidarité un peu baissé dans le
sport pour des pour des raisons
évidentes malheureusement stable sur
l'environnement avec 6% émission je vous
dis malheureusement parce que on sait
que c'est une attente de 98% des jeunes
parce que c'est ce qu'ils nous disent et
dans l'offre de missions que nous avons
assez un peu évidemment de sa des
attentes des jeunes donc c'est d'où
l'intérêt de travailler avec le mca la
transition écologique et solidaire
les grandes associations d'environnement
ou d'introduire des questions
environnementales dans des missions des
missions plus traditionnels comme le
sport c'est un sujet dont on parle et
lundi avec tony estanguet donc j'espère
que dans les deux ans qui viennent on
pourra vraiment augmenter fortement
cette thématique environnementale dans
les missions de service civique sur les
profils
donc l'âge moyen 21 ans n'a pas bougé 61
% de femmes 39 % d'hommes ça n'a pas
bougé 8% des volontaires bénéficient de
l'indemnité complémentaire sur critères
sociaux
là je crois que ça augmenté de 2% non ça
c'est 2020 donc voilà oui donc ça
augmenté de 2% par rapport à 2019
là où il ya eu une évolution qui se
confirme en 2021 c'est sur les étudiants
traditionnellement 30% nous en avions
parlé lors de la précédente audition la
précédente rencontre c'est les étudiants
en service civique sont à peu près 30%
des effectifs aujourd'hui on est à 30 4%
dont a pu en plus je vous avais raconté
la dernière fois tout ce qui a été mis
en place pour permettre à plus
d'étudiants d'entrer en service civique
est de concilier service civique et
études
donc ça a l'air d'avoir un impact sur
nos chiffres ce qui est positif et dans
le même temps on doit face à ne doit pas
non plus dépasser ses 34 ou 35 % parce
qu'il faut veiller à au principe
d'accessibilité du service civique voilà
je pense que j'étais merci et sont elles
trop longue
non non c'était très intéressant je
pense qu'on va revenir à travers les
questions sur un certain nombre de
points
jacques bernard magner rapporteur des
crédits budgétaires
merci monsieur le président merci ben la
présidente de votre exposé et
félicitations aussi à vous deux général
pour avoir rempli autant que possible
les objectifs qu'ils n'étaient pas
faciles à atteindre
on est dans une période difficile aussi
bien pour le monde associatif que pour
les jeunes que pour trouver des missions
parce que plus cent mille jeunes + 100
mille jeunes c'est facile à trouver plus
cent mille mission c'est plus difficile
à trouver j'imagine parce que
aujourd'hui il y a effectivement des
secteurs que vous
que vous investissez qui sont des
secteurs nouveaux tant mieux et je
dirais même qu'il y en aura certainement
de nouveaux qui vont s'ouvrir dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent
puisque vous l'avez évoqué les jeux
olympiques vous avez parlé avec tony
estanguet je pense que c'est une
magnifique source de recrutement pour
des jeunes en service civique dans la
région parisienne essentiellement mais
c'est bien cela qu'il faut effectivement
s'attacher puisque les jeunes de la
région parisienne mérite bien un effet
qui s'occupe d'eux aussi parce qu'ils
ont assez souffert pendant ses pairs du
confinement donc aujourd'hui vous avez
obtenus nous avons ensemble obtenu
puisque le président la fondent
rappelait le sénat est derrière vous
j'imagine l'assemblée nationale aussi
les assemblées sont avec vous pour
soutenir ce service civique i qui a
maintenant un peu plus de dix ans et qui
a pu voir venir à lui plus de 500000
plus d'un demi million de jeunes c'est
pas né sais pas c'est pas négligeable
même si on aurait pu être encore un peu
plus ambitieux pour les objectifs du
nombre de jeunes de concernées par le
service civique c'est un peu dommage
qu'on ait détourné l'attention en créant
en voulant créer un service national
universel qui à mon avis va certainement
pollue un peu même s'ils intègrent ce
service d'assurer diverses le service
civique est ce à l'intérieur d'une
certaine manière mais j'ai mis
l'impression qu'on va mettre beaucoup de
moyens sur un service national universel
qui ne remplira un modèle est
difficilement des objectifs alors que le
service civique lui il est installé
depuis dix ans il fonctionne bien on
sait comment elle doit fonctionner on
sait aussi quels sont les inconvénients
et les contraintes
moi je ne vous avais dit que beaucoup de
jeunes dans certains secteurs sont
maintenant en service civique jeu
notamment dans les collectivités qui
commencent à s'y intéresser
il faut quand même qu'on soit vigilant
pour que si les jeunes du service
civique ne remplace pas les emplois
aidés qui ont été supprimés dans les
dents les collectivités massivement
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas du tout le
même objectif
agen dans le service civique il n'a pas
remplacer un salarié futile d'un salarié
un contractuel tout cela il faut être
très vigilant notamment avec les
collectivités locales mais je crois
qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'elles donnent
aussi il ya des quelle force un peu plus
sur la pourcentage parce que 6 % vous
l'avez dit c'est fait c'est peu il
faudra plus et puis il ya aussi un
secteur sur lequel on vous sollicite
régulièrement sont les territoires
ruraux
c'est plus difficile de mettre en place
on le sait bien et sa vie civique mais
je sais que vous avez lancé une mission
avec les territoires ruraux pour voir si
on peut développer
c'est un appel à manifestation d'intérêt
avait été lancé au mois deux mois
d'avril vous nous direz si ça ne
commence à frémir et si on a quelques
résultats
et puis effectivement vous avez évoqué
toutes ces nouvelles thématiques lundi
kent on peut développer le service
civique
je pense que la crise sanitaire nous a
montré qu'il y a certainement des
espaces où le service civique peut être
précieux alors la question budgétaire
vous l'avez évoqué est ce que les 245
milles que vous avez eue en 2021 seront
maintenus re budget 2022
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on vous
soutiennent et nous ferons ici au niveau
de caen nous étudierons le projet de loi
de finances de 8,22 est-ce que vous avez
là dessus aussi des informations sur les
ambitions qui sont qui seront développés
pour le service civique au niveau
budgétaire en 2022
ensuite à ce qui a été fait pendant
cette période
cette période de crise sanitaire qui
espérons le et derrière nous que nous
reverrons pas assez développé l'année
prochaine voilà j'en assume est plus
lent presque j'imagine que mes collègues
des questions merci je vous laisse
répondre cette première série de
questions puis
d'autres collègues qui interviendront
par la suite merci monsieur
effectivement vous avez relevé un
paradoxe c'est cent mille jeunes
supplémentaires c'est facile à trouver
cent mille mission c'est moins facile et
que le résultat est que effectivement on
a moins en moins de jeunes qu'espéré
parce que l'offre et la demande pour
parler simplement ne ne correspondent
pas encore tout à fait j'espère vous
avoir convaincus que notre notre
stratégie est la bonne mais en tout cas
effectivement on est absolument certain
du fait que l'élan pour le service
civique le désir pour le service civique
il existe dans la jeunesse française
preuve en est on a eu entre 1er janvier
et le 30 avr
30 mai ou 30 avril je sais plus 470
mille inscriptions pour des candidatures
sur le site internet donc voilà ça veut
dire que les jeunes savent trouver notre
site et qu'ils ont envie de s'engager au
service civique pour des raisons
d'ailleurs qui sont qui sont variés un
certain parce qu'ils veulent vraiment
s'engager la majorité j'espère mais
d'autres c'est plus ambigu sur ce qu'ils
savent pas très bien quoi faire ou parce
qu'ils ont besoin d'une indemnité mais
pour moi ce qui compte c'est le déclic
c'est à dire ce qui va se passer dans le
service civique qui fait que cette
expérience va leur être utile pour eux
mêmes et puis ensuite pour le suite de
leur vie personnelle citoyenne et
professionnels donc merci d'avoir
souligné
ce paradoxe monsieur le sénateur sur le
sn eu une opposition à est assez
pragmatique le fmi était une priorité du
gouvernement
comment le service civique peut en
bénéficier
et comme l'a dit le président de la
république le s le service civique dans
le oui le snuipp-93 civique et le
venezuela donc vraiment l'idée c'est que
le service civique et salaires pourra
m'être déplacé là trois fois
ces cinq derniers jours sur des séjours
de cohésion du ce du sns a l'air d'être
bien parti pour que on considère que le
service civique et le fn y ont des liens
intrinsèques et que le service civique
sera vraiment une composante majeure de
la phase iii du s est nu viendra ensuite
la question des moyens parce que plus on
aura de jeunes qui auront entendu parler
du service civique dans les enseignes
qui voudront ensuite entré ans habitait
plus faudra qu'on travaille sur cette
montée en charge qui a forcément
forcément un coût mais en tout cas je
crois que sur la logique de l'ingénierie
de et la complicité complémentarité
entre les deux dispositifs entre
guillemets je pense que ça peut assez
bien assez bien fonctionné collectivités
territoriales puis ensuite sur la
réalité
elodie vous donnera les premiers
chiffres les résultats de l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt donc je voulais
dire sur les collectivités territoriales
une augmentation de 50% désagréments en
deux mots et bien sûr ce point
d'attention sur la qualité parce que
attentes dans les services publics au
sens large soit territoriaux ou
nationaux mais il ya peut-être peut-être
cette tentation effectivement de
remplacer des agents publics par des
services évident qu'ils ne coûtent entre
guillemets que 107 euros par mois à
l'organisme qui les accueillent
on a mis tout en place tout un système
de vigiles ont déjà des l'agrément à la
fois par l' agence mais par les services
déconcentrés de l'état de bien contrôler
les demandes le fait qu'on est aussi
revu tout tout notre communication en
direction des collectivités
territoriales avec un flyer dédié avec
surtout des exemples de missions des
bonnes pratiques on a fait aussi
beaucoup de webinaires avec sous la
houlette des prêts faits notamment les
préfètes d'ailleurs c'était à l'égalité
des chances a fait des webinaires qui
ont vraiment grand succès dans le 93 76
participants en auvergne rhône-alpes 110
pour informer vraiment
les collectivités territoriales de ce
qu'elle service civique avec bon toutes
ces opportunités et puis bien sûr ses
fondamentaux et entre guillemets ses
contraintes
donc je pense qu'on a mis les garde-fous
mis en place des garde-fous nécessaires
avec le relais des référents
territoriaux
voilà sur les collectivités thériault et
c'est vrai que je vais vous dire qu'au
mondial à la crise est entre guillemets
une opportunité pour le service civique
dans les collectivités taga mais
vraiment je mets des dj mais bien gras
parce que effectivement les
collectivités les communes et les
départements
ils ont pour compétence des domaines qui
propose des possibilités de
développement de missions notamment en
lien avec la crise on voit là c'est
aussi ce qui peut expliquer la montée en
charge après la question de la
durabilité de ses missions dans les
collectivités territoriales se posera
mais pour l'instant on est vraiment sur
des thématiques grand âge handicap
culture continuité pédagogique santé
donc je suis assez confiante sur le fait
que ce soit vraiment en complémentarité
des missions des agents publics et audi
je voulais cela la ruralité on a dit oui
oui donc sur la réalité c'est sûr que ça
un objectif particulièrement important
qu'on se fixe qui rentrent en fait dans
notre objectif global dans un des
fondamentaux du service vie qui est
l'accessibilité donc l'accessibilité
que ce soit en terme de jeu nous que ce
soit en terme de territoire donc en
effet l'accessibilité du service civique
pour les jeunes en territoire ce bureau
et y compris la possibilité pour les
organismes de trouver des jeunes parce
que madame la présidente l'a dit on a
beaucoup plus de jeunes qui postulent
que deux missions aujourd'hui le ratio
c'est à peu près quatre candidatures
pour une mission mais on a quand même
dans certains territoires ruraux des
organismes des collectivités qui nous
remontent des difficultés à recruter en
disant moi j'ai posé sur votre site
internet démission et je n'ai eu aucune
candidature parce que voilà difficultés
de transport difficultés de logement
donc c'est évidemment un sujet auquel on
a été sensibilisé donc on a lancé en
effet un appel à manifestation d'intérêt
au mois d'avril
donc on avait ciblé sur 15 départements
ouvert aux communes et aux pc on a eu
neuf lauréats pour un total d'à peu près
400 mille euros et ça nous a permis
on avait eu 13 candidatures ça nous a
permis de financer justement différents
projets pour permettre à ces deux pays
de développer des missions de service
civique et de travailler sur
l'accessibilité justement dans dans ces
territoires ruraux et fort de ce premier
succès on a lancé un deuxième appel à
manifestation d'intérêt qu'on a
davantage ouvert là on l'a ouvert sur 52
départements c'est-à-dire tous les
départements dans lesquels on avait à
peu près plus de la moitié de la
population qui réside dans un territoire
rural donc on a décidé d'élargir le
périmètre dont elle a décidé aussi de
l'ouvrir potentiellement à des
collectivités qui pouvait être déjà
agréé cerdan le premier ennemi on avait
vraiment recentrer sur vous voulez
développer voire connaître le service
civique que là on a aussi été ciblés sur
vous est déjà agréé mais par exemple
vous n'avez pas réussi à transformer
l'essai sur vous avez justement essayer
de publier démission mais ça n'a pas
fonctionné
dans ce cas là l' agence va aussi vous
accompagner pour développer des nouveaux
moyens devraient augmenter votre
agrément augmenter votre poste où
commencer les premiers recrutements
parce que ça n'a pas pu ça n'a pas pu
fonctionner la fin de cette année miss
et le 13 juillet donc pour l'instant on
n'a pas encore les résultats et on a
augmenté le budget en conséquence de cet
élargissement du du périmètre donc je
pense qu'on n'a pas encore les résultats
à vous transmettre mais mais mais on
voulait transmettra et sur la question
des objectifs pour pour 2022
donc et leviers dont il assure vous
vouliez compléter sur la ruralité pour
bien souligner le fait que
les moyens complémentaires que nous
donnons
qui sont d un budget qui va servir à de
l'ingéniérie 1 permet donc aux
collectivités de créer un poste pour
dédié pour le déploiement du service
civique dont sillage et l'exemple du pde
conjuguant leurs donc 2646 habitants
répartis dans 25 communes
il vise l'accueil de 20 volontaires en
service civique un pur en fait
redynamiser le territoire travailler sur
les éco-gestes et l'argent dont ils vont
bénéficier va leur permettre de créer un
poste de coordinateur qui va travailler
avec toutes les communes de cette
communauté de communes pour mettre tout
ça en place puisque évidemment ça tombe
pas ça tombe pas du ciel pour
retransmettre les exemples on a dans le
pays des écrins qu'il est cher les
jeunes issus pour une collation jeu
voilà des choses des choses vraiment
intéressantes et j'aimerais que les
difficultés elodie l'a bien dit là où il
faut qu'on travaille avec des financeurs
complémentaire avec les régions c'est
pour la prise en charge de l'hébergement
et de la mobilité parce que je veux
rappeler que le service ico fait l'agent
ce qu'on s'a 90 % de son budget à
indemniser les jeunes et pour le reste
est à titre personnel je ça me manque un
peu on peut pas apporter de moyens
supplémentaires surtout là quelques
quelques exceptions comme des appels à
projets ou des amis mais si voilà ce
qu'il faut arriver à faire c'est qu'on
est par exemple fondation sncf par
exemple un qui sponsorise entre
guillemets à une collectivité de
communes pour permettre à d qui
permettrait à des jeunes avec cet argent
supplémentaire les communes pourrait
indemniser les jeunes sur les frais de
transport qui pourrait avoir un exemple
très intéressant d'une association qui a
commencé avec cinq jeunes en service
civique incity là ils ont développé un
programme maintenant avec quarante
jeunes ça s'appelle erasmus rural
vraiment un travail extraordinaire je
trouve ou en fait ils font venir des
jeunes d'autres territoires qui sont
hébergés chez l'habitant
et donc les jeunes dans sa musique passe
de six à huit mois dans des territoires
le gers la nouvelle aquitaine maintenant
enfin des départements la nouvelle qui
est peut-être sont concernés ils
travaillent sur la route d'une
humanisation du territoire a créé des
épiceries solidaires ils voyaient ya la
prise en charge de l'hébergement et puis
voilà ils ont trouvé des petits sponsors
aussi pour compléter les dépenses le de
mobilité pardon elodie je vous ai je la
je vous arrêter leur très lent sur le
budget avant de vous redonner la parole
je voudrais dire un mot sur une
composante un sous jacent comme on dit
maintenant entre temps j'ai appris dans
le budget qui est essentiel c'est la
durée des missions de service civique
on a eu un débat en 2020 on en avait
parlé dans dans cette assemblée un sur
le fait que avec l'augmentation de la
civ à 145 mille jeunes à l'époque et le
budget dédié
nous ne pouvions plus financer à peu
près huit mois en moyenne et on sait que
c'est ça le besoin des jeunes ces huit
mois en moyenne parce que ça permet pour
certains jeunes de faire dix mois pour
d'autres 6 1
donc avec le budget au plf à au budget
initial 2020 on a eu cette question de
la durée des missions qu'on pouvait qu
on a dû réduire à 7 mois qui a généré un
très grand témoin dans l'ensemble de la
communauté du service civique que ce
soit dans l'éducation nationale dans la
vie associative et j'allais dire
heureusement avec le plan de relance on
a vu des moins les moyens
complémentaires pour les familles une
mission plus les 80000 en 2021 nous ont
permis de ramener à 8 mois en moyenne la
durée des missions donc la question
avant de redonner à parallèle le dit la
question pour une des questions mais
pour moi une qui est importante pour
2021 ça va être
voilà ce sous jacent essentiel de la
durée des missions qui pour nous ne doit
pas être une variable d'ajustement parce
que là ça se saura tout de suite dès
l'automne
et ça risque de générer un découragement
dans l'écosystème du service civique et
donc on
d'avoir un jeune ou un stop and go
difficile pardon oui c'est pas lui moi
n'est pas le grade c'est juste que ça
nous permet voilà ça nous permet
vraiment parfois pour certains jeunes
d'être sûre quasiment l'année scolaire
et pour d'autres un étudiant qui
commence en janvier qui fait 6 mois
d'août elle je vous laisse dire un petit
peu les nos besoins pour 2021 et hier
pour l'instant les discussions
budgétaires n'en sont qu'à leur qu'à
leurs débuts
oui je pense qu'il ya en effet le double
sujet volume est dur et nous on milite
vraiment évidemment pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de stop and go
donc on reste sur la dynamique de 245
milles en 2022
sachant que si on se contente entre
guillemets de maintenir l'objectif à 245
milles ça veut dire très concrètement
qu'en termes de flux comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure si à long terme de
nouvelles entrées on sera vraiment sur
une stabilisation cirque sur une très
faible baisse du flux mais on sera à peu
près à la même chose que l inverse si on
rabaisse cet objectif par exemple à 200
milles
là on va baisser le flux c'est à dire la
possibilité pour les jeunes de rentrer
en mission de service civique d'à peu
près 40%
donc ça veut dire qu'on aura demandé aux
organismes de créer des nouvelles
missions d'investir dans des tuteurs d'
d'investir dû justement dans tout un
dispositif qui permet d'accompagner les
jeunes de créer des emplois d'avenir on
aura aussi sollicité dans dead et des
projets d'avenir de projets d'avenir
pardon on aura aussi solliciter les
jeunes qui seront les postuler sur notre
site internet etc et en 2022 on leur
dirait mais en fait non on n'a plus
assez de nouveaux postes pour vous parce
que le stock est déjà pris entre
guillemets et donc on irait presque
reprendre des missions qu'on a incité à
faire en 2021 et ça pour nous c'est
voilà c'était vraiment l'argument
qu'on a c'est de dire qu'il faut sortir
juste faut pas juste se dire 245000
c'est juste une stabilité et si ces deux
cent mille c'est juste une petite baisse
vraiment à se dire aussi qu'on
l'appliqué en termes de nouvelles
entrées en terme en termes de flux
chaque année et c'est en regardant cet
indicateur la queue il nous semble
particulièrement important de maintenir
un minimum à 245 millions en 2020 pour
nous
l'alternative c'est 245 mission à 8 mois
où l' inverse
voyez voilà c'est fait
c'était calculé les verts sont les
jachères il n'ya pas d'averses ses 245
milles à 8 mois ou huit mois pour des
cinq points de famille met d'accord
voilà alors on continue les questions
annick billon merci monsieur le
président madame la présidente madame la
secrétaire générale d'abord vous
remercier pour ses premières réponses je
vais avoir très peu de questions en
réalité pour rassurer mon collègue qui
m'interrogeait de chergé beaucoup de
questions claude kern donc d'abord sûr
je ne suis pas rapporteur je ne suis pas
à porter ce texte s'est déjà exprimée
attention ça va rallonger les débats si
on rentre dans ce sur cette thématique
donc comment garantir vous l'avait déjà
expliqué le fait de de substituer le
service le service civique qui se
substituerait à des emplois vous savez
évoqué contrôler les demandes grâce à
des flyers des webinaires moi je
voudrais vraiment vous dire qu'il ya un
vrai risque sur cette thématique et que
en dehors d'une volonté de ne pas
substituer des emplois par le service
civique
on va pas y arriver et donc ça me paraît
extrêmement difficile à contrôler et je
voulais vous dire que j'avais des doutes
par rapport à l'efficacité de ses outils
dont vous avez parlé
un deuxième point sur l'égalité en femme
vous avez dit que ça faisait partie de
thématiques nouvelles
donc comment avez vous identifié les
besoins parce que comment allez vous
attirer des jeunes vers ces thématiques
même si c'est une thématique qui sur le
devant de l'actualité régulièrement
on sait aujourd'hui que les associations
sont les premiers acteurs dans la lutte
contre les violences notamment et que
ces associations elles sont en déficit
de moyens
donc là encore pour cette thématique y
at-il pas un risque à substituer des
personnes qui ont besoin normalement de
formation de compétences réelles pour
pouvoir accompagner ces femmes par
exemple victimes de violences par le
service civique donc il ya un risque
supplémentaire sur cette thématique
alors qu'on sait que les associations
elles sont les premiers acteurs est très
demandeur de moyens également
et puis sur la répartition des
structures vous avez annoncé un des
structures nouvelles et bien vous pouvez
vous nous dire la répartition
territoriale de ces structures
et comme il n'a pas été question des
territoires ultramarins
comment se transpose tous toutes ces
mesures sur les territoires ultramarins
jour merci et c'était une petite note
drôle que je voulais faire un clin
d'oeil à mon collègue claire en début
d'intervention merci ce que je vous
propose c'est de regrouper toutes les
questions et en continuant par céline
brulin président merci mesdames je vais
être un peu redondante avec les deux
intervenants précédents parce que
effectivement on a tous des questions
qui tournent autour de la frontière
entre
le service civique dont tout le monde
reconnaît effectivement l'intérêt est
que vous avez parfaitement bien
démontrer et des emplois aidés ou pas
qui pourrait se confondre avec ça vous
avez expliqué votre vigilance et les
outils que vous mettez en place pour
contrôler le mot et pas très joli mais
ça mais moi je constate que même si vous
avez obtenu des moyens supplémentaires
dans une période récente
périmètre de lagence c'est quand même
pas énorme pour effectivement être sur
le terrain et être en vigilance par
rapport à tout ce qui se passe et puis
surtout on est dans une période
économique dégradé que ce soit pour les
collectivités que ce soit pour le tissu
associatif et du coup il ya peut-être
des dérives supplémentaires qu'ils
n'avaient pas cours au démarrage du
dispositif qui peuvent peut-être
intervenir parce que chacun on va
essayer de faire au mieux avec les
moyens qu'il a donc c'est aussi là
dessus que je voulais intervenir et
d'ailleurs pas seulement sur le tissu
associatif et les collectivités puisque
je pense que l'état doit se montrer
exemplaire en la matière et qui a
parfois eu des annonces notamment du
côté du ministère de l'éducation
nationale qui pouvait laisser entendre
que ses services civiques pourrait par
exemple aux côtés des directeurs d'école
et sait jouer un rôle qui se rapproche
plus à mes yeux d'un emploi donc c'est
pas une question mais j'aimerais qu'on
creuse encore davantage ce sujet une
question dont je m'étonne que c'est une
blague là aussi annick billon ne l'est
pas posée il m'a semblé relever dans
votre il me semblait relever dans votre
exposé que la répartition hommes-femmes
c'était 40 60 en gros comment est ce que
vous expliquez ce différentiel qui est
quand même assez important je n'ose
imaginer que les femmes s'engagent plus
que les hommes et puis et puis sur sûr
vous avez évoqué les 530 mille jeunes
qui ont qui ont effectué une mission
c'est vrai que c'est très très important
est ce que
il ya matière là alors j'ai encore une
fois je vois que vos moyens sont
extrêmement limitées même si vous
développez de l'énergie mais ce qu'il
n'y a pas matière désormais à une étude
un peu qualitative pour voir quels
seraient les effets bénéfiques de ce
service civique sur à plus long terme la
vie des jeunes professionnellement est
ce que est ce que ça se traduit par une
engagement qui perdure enfin ça pourrait
être intéressant il me semble d'avoir
cette vision un peu à long terme jours
claudine lepage
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la présidente madame la secrétaire
générale
donc merci pour votre présentation nous
suivons avec attention l'évolution du
service civique depuis l'adoption de la
loi portée par martin hirsch en 2010
pour ma part notamment sur l'envoi de
jeunes en service civique à l'étranger
et j'aimerais vous interrogé aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet alors aujourd'hui quel est
le pourcentage des jeunes envoyer sur
des missions à l'étranger quel type de
mission
dans quel pays bénéficie-t-il d'une
formation même brève en amont en 2020
lors de la fermeture des frontières
l'arrêt des vols commerciaux
que s'est il passé pour les jeunes en
mission à l'étranger
certains ont peut être eu des problèmes
de visa par exemple s'il était en fin de
mission de revenus se trouvait à
l'étranger sans aucun revenu n'est pas
une situation confortable
ont-ils pu être rapatrié le votre agence
at elle pu mettre en oeuvre des moyens
pour les rapatrier et un dernier point
sur l'égalité hommes femmes
ça n'a plus rien à voir avec l'étranger
de quelle manière les jeunes en service
civique peuvent-ils intervenir sur
l'égalité hommes femmes par exemple
s'agit-il d'intervention dans les
établissements scolaires ou de quelle
manière interviennent t-il je vous
remercie pierre entre de lévis
oui merci monsieur le président la
présidente secrétaire général lors je
revends ni sur la question d'un
aiguillon concernant le lait crème que
nous avons sur l'utilisation des
services civiques pour des emplois on
sait qu'il devienne une variable
d'ajustement de la politique rh de
certaines administrations
moi je sais quelques quelques questions
peut-être un peu direct si des dérives
sont constatées
est-ce que vous avez déjà retiré un
agrément une administration pour
l'accueil de service civique
si ce n'était pas le cas est ce que vous
auriez le faire quelles solutions
l'agencé nationale du service civique
met-elle en oeuvre pour garantir le
respect des engagements des
administrations accueillante
ça c'était deux premières questions une
question concernant la suite du service
civique puisque plus on sait pour avoir
été sollicité par beaucoup de jeunes
pour trouver un emploi c'est qu'à la
suite de ce service civique
certains jeunes galèrent pour trouver un
emploi je sais que j'ai mis des
processus en place pour les aider mais
est-ce que vous pouvez aller plus loin
et nous dire si vous avez une méthode
pour pouvoir les aider davantage
est-ce que selon vous c'est une des
solutions ne pourrait-elle pas être le
droit à une indemnisation chômage
puisque avant 25 ans ces jeunes n'ont
pas droit au rsa
voilà toute une série de questions des
c'est y répondre
qui montre en tout cas vous voyez
d'intérêts des membres de la commission
pour le service civique
voilà alors sur la question tout à fait
légitime est essentiel de substitution à
l'emploi frontières service civique
emploi risque de dérive et donc le
corollaire le contrôle alors
effectivement il ya je peux vous dire
11% des organismes sont sont contrôlés
il ya onze mille après près de onze
mille organisme agréé donc on peut pas
tout contrôler c'est certain je vais pas
vous mentir en vous disant linverse 11%
est plutôt un gros un chiffre important
puisque nous étions à 8 5% il ya trois
ans donc une augmentation forte ce qui
est important tout autant que le
contrôle c'est la pédagogie
l'explication en amont ce qui suppose
donc des l'agrément on appelle ça dans
notre jargon ça veut dire de proposer
des réunions d'abord de bien former nos
référents territoriaux que ici parce que
aujourd'hui l' agence du service civique
à gré 500 gros organisme au plan
national et le reste est agréé au plan
territorial par les services
déconcentrés de l'état qui ont fait
l'objet en 2020 d'une réorganisation ils
sont maintenant adossé au rectorat de
régions académiques dans des
organisations qui s'appelle les draps
ges ils ont en même temps à faire face
entre guillemets un essai en même temps
responsable du sn eu des vacances
apprenant des accueils collectifs de
mineurs donc c'est vraiment des agents
qui ont beaucoup de travail donc il faut
qu'on les outils à faire ce à faire
c'est ce travail de contrôle est plutôt
de vigilance des l'agrément de
de l'adéquation des missions demandé des
dossiers déposés à conformité aux
agréments aux fondamentaux du service
civique
donc il ya ça il ya l'outillage à la
fois des agents de l'agencé
et puis des services déconcentrés il ya
aussi tout le travail d'information de
l'agencé elle-même avec des réunions
d'information de développer ces derniers
temps beaucoup de webinaires je pense
qu'on va d'ailleurs les pérenniser parce
qu'en fait ça s'est avéré très très très
utile voilà il ya le suivi des
organismes et puis effectivement il ya
ensuite le contrôle et parfois de
retirer désagréments n'ont juste pas ça
doit être une dizaine au moins une
dizaine ou par an et sur les organismes
publics bien sûr qu'on peut c'est arrivé
dans une sous préfecture
c'est arrivé ça devait arriver dans une
agence pôle emploi finalement ils ont
remis les choses en place assez
rapidement donc nous avons levé à la
entre guillemets menace de retirer
l'agrément mais voilà ça arrive aussi
dans des établissements scolaires
là on essaie vraiment bien sûr on est un
organisme d'état mais on travaille en
indépendance aussi pour que les mêmes
règles s'appliquent à tous à tous les
organismes donc voilà il ya la vigilance
des l'agrément il ya le contrôle le
contrôle c'est rossi voilà c'est aussi
un message quand vous retirez une
un agrément une association qui par
ailleurs sur son territoire a pignon sur
rue
ça se sait donc ça oblige quand même les
autres à se remettre en question
pareille pour pour les sous-préfectures
et pour moi l'avenir et je vous remercie
de me poser ces questions très concrètes
parce que moi je suis assez idéaliste je
voudrais pas que vous croyez que je sois
dans l'incantation je suis aussi dans le
dans le terrain dans la réalité des des
faits et pour moi vraiment ce qui fait
la différence entre un service civique
et un emploi c'est ce qu'on appelle les
différenciant à l'agencé la formation
civique et citoyenne
c'est le fait que chaque jeune soit
accompagnée avec sérieux et persévérance
et fiabilité par un tuteur un tuteur qui
est formé par l' agence à l'obligation
du tuteur la formation du tuteur est une
obligation légale donc je crois que
c'est c'est parce que contrôler si vous
voulez tous les toutes les missions de
tous les jeunes se sera jamais possible
ça l'était déjà pas le hall ce n'était
déjà pas le cas avec 6000 jeunes en 2010
avec martin hirsch donc encore mois
encore moins à 200 à 245 milles en
revanche d'appuyer sur vraiment les
différenciant c'est à dire la formation
que civique et citoyenne qui pour moi
malgré le coût que cela représente 2
devrait passer à 5 jours obligatoires au
lieu de trois par exemple de contrôler
plus la formation des tuteurs et
d'assurer ce que j'appelais tout à
l'heure l'animation de la communauté des
volontaires de générer
un sentiment d'appartenance tout ça
c'est des choses qui vont faire que le
jeune en service civique qui va se dire
bah oui en fait je fais pas la même
chose qu'un agent public parce que je
rencontre d'autres volontaires sur mon
territoire parce que l' agence de
fourmies me fournit des outils m'aide à
me donne des informations pour l'après
service civique parce que mon tuteur est
un bon tuteur qu'il est fort mais c'est
pas un maître de stage mais c'est plutôt
un tuteur au sens du mentor parce que
j'accède à des formations civiques et
citoyennes qui me parle de laïcité de
valeur de vote etc et non pas ne me
parle pas de la détache que je dois
remplir au quotidien dans ma mission
c'est pour moi c'est vraiment ça
l'avenir sur le travail l'avenir du
travail sur les différenciant des
services il y emploie emploi mission
d'engagement sur l'égalité femmes-hommes
alors merci voilà je vois qu'il ya
unanimité sur cette préoccupation que je
partage vous vous en doutez donc en fait
pour y arriver je crois qu'il faut
travailler comme on l'a fait déjà avec
les caf à la réunion i avec qu'ils ont
créé une corde d'ambassadeur de
l'égalité femmes hommes des jeunes qui
sont formés par la caf qui circulent
dans les quartiers n'ont pas seul mais
avec leur tuteur ou un responsable
associatif parce qu'il ya une
coopération entre café une association
de la réunion voilà pour prévenir
informer alors évidemment c'est pas du
soin ça se substitue pas à ce que peut
faire vraiment l'association dans sa
raison d'être mais c'est toujours un
support il faut savoir que sur ces
grandes ces grands enjeux sociétaux
quand les jeunes en service civique
ça vaut par exemple de l'association
aides où ils sont là en support pour
faire de la pédagogie pour parler à
leurs pairs ça fonctionne vraiment très
bien
1 pour proposer aussi aux associations
de nouveaux modes d'intervention parce
que jeune en service civique il arrive
avec ses compétences avec son
savoir-faire son savoir-être et il
permet aussi aux interventions
d'évoluer donc voilà c'est plutôt ça
qu'on fait et évidemment on ne peut pas
les jeunes ne peuvent pas se substituer
entre nîmes et des professionnels de ces
de ces questions là mais je crois pour
autant qu'il faut qu'on reste
persévérant sur cette thématique parce
que d'abord à l'intérêt ce beaucoup les
jeunes qui on garde la consultation
citoyenne qu'on a lancé en 2010 à
l'occasion de nos dix ans est la
deuxième cause l'égalité femmes-hommes
plébiscité après le développement
durable donc si on veut répondre aux
attentes des jeunes il faut qu'on soit
qu'on développe des missions dans toutes
les vigilances qui s'imposent si je
regarde ce contrat fait en ce moment
avec la fondation des femmes
on va développer des missions
d'ambassadeur de l'égalité qui seront
mis à disposition du train de l'égalité
qui est en train de en train de
développer la fondation des femmes
on a des jeunes en service civique à la
sauce appel à paris la cité glorieuses
c'est ça pardon j'ai le terme échappant
bons qui sont dans l'information la
pédagogie l'accueil le premier accueille
aussi parfois des personnes jamais seul
bon je pense qu'on doit quand même voilà
qu'on est dans le respect des
fondamentaux et que ça fonctionne assez
bien sûr le 40/60 bon en fait la réponse
est dans votre question 1
alors surtout toutes les toutes les
thématiques qui tourne autour du caire
et du social on a plus de femmes
on est très vigilant c'est pour ça que
par exemple sur le sport on essaie de
développer plus de missions le programme
génération 24 développé avec le cojo
l'adij hop le cnosf je pense peut nous
aider aussi attiré plus de garçons
pardon si jean georges enfonce les
portes ouvertes mais force est de
constater qu'on à 70 % de jeunes gens
dans l'émission de sport donc où l'a
d'ailleurs puisque je vous parle de ce
programme génération 24 sur ses seins
2024 c'est un programme qui tourne
autour de l'engagement social du sport
avec une déclinaison importante sur le
soutien à la pratique féminine et
l'égalité femmes-hommes dans dans le
sport sur la question de la répartition
territoriale je peux pas vous la ddt
mais je pourrais vous l'a évidemment
vous là vous la transmettre répartition
territoriale des jeunes et des types de
structures sur l'outre-mer là je connais
de tête la répartition territoriale
c'est que dans les autres mais on a plus
de jeunes dans les services de l'état
que dans les associations c'est à peu
près 60% de jeunes par exemple hier
j'avais rendez vous avec le directeur
général culture jeunesse de la guyane
faire rendez-vous en visio et en guyane
c'est 54 % de jeunes en service civique
dans les mêmes dans les services de
l'état à la martinique c'est près la
réunion c'est près de 60% les outre mer
sont très importants prioritaire pour
nous un c'est un sujet que je connais
assez bien pour même pour m'être déplacé
mais où évidemment la vigilance qu'il
faut avoir entre sur cette frontière
entre services et autres missiles entre
emploi et travail d'agent public est
encore plus important parce qu'on a
vraiment des jeunes qui sont souvent
motivés quand même parrain du fait du
faible du coût de la vie et du taux de
chômage très important dans les familles
chez les jeunes souvent les jeunes sont
quand même particulièrement motivé par
l'indemnité donc sans doute un peu moins
exigeants sur la nature des missions et
ça peut développer quelques voilà enfin
des dérives que nous regardons d'assez
près mais soyez certaine que les outre
mer sont vraiment important pour nous
qu'est ce que j'aurais pu encore oublié
le plan non il y avait foule sur la
presse service civique et sur
l'international oui d'abord pour vous
dire pardon j'ai oublié sur la question
comment comment on contrôle la
différence entre service civique emploi
je vous ai dit faut vraiment travailler
sur les différenciant il ya une
expérimentation que nous avons avec pôle
emploi renouvelle aquitaine et d'autres
que nous aurons cet été avec l'éducation
nationale dans le cadre des vacances
apprenantes que je classe en deux en
deux mots c'est panachage et enjambement
alors le panachage c'est quand un jeune
en mission
à pôle emploi il est plutôt sur des
missions de pédagogie du numérique
présent chat prise en main il aide les
demandeurs d'emploi à prendre en main
les outils numériques
on a considéré à la faveur du du
contrôle c'est pas un secret un de pôle
emploi que ces missions étaient un peu
répétitive même répétitives et donc moi
j'ai demandé au directeur général de
pôle emploi de travail et un panachage
des missions expérimentations en cours
la nouvelle à petit n où un jeune
enfin les jeunes en en mission chez pôle
emploi passeront deux 2 jours par
semaine dans des associations du
territoire sur la l'occurrence
l'expérimentation c'est avec la croix
rouge pour diversifier leurs activités
ça ça me paraît vraiment une piste très
intéressante pour l'émission qui se
déroule dans l'est dans les services
publics ou les établissements publics ou
souvent ça tourne autour des prises en
main des outils numériques avec un
risque vraiment de routine donc le
panachage première réponse et pardon de
voilà de mon retour en arrière et la
question de l'engendrement c'est sur
l'éducation nationale il y aura donc
39000 mission si tout va bien à la fin
2021 ce soir 39 me ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est pour certains jeunes sur
certains territoires on sait que des
programmes comme l'école ouverte où les
vacances apprenants sont très développés
c'est que de faire entrer la maintenant
des jeunes en service civique sur des
contrats établissements scolaires qu'ils
soient mis à disposition ces jeunes des
collectivités territoriales le plus
souvent ou des ou des fédérations
d'éducation populaire qui seront en
charge les vacances apprenantes 1 pour
être être en support de la mise en place
deux de ses possibilités pour pour les
jeunes et ensuite de retrouver leur
établissement scolaire à à la rentrée
donc ça c'est des choses on en est
encore à l'état d'expérimentation mais
qui nous permettent vraiment de
travailler sur la différence service
civique et emploi par temps dédié est
revenu
après avoir traité la question d'égalité
femmes hommes et il y avait donc oui
alors ensuite sur la presse hervé
civique les effets bénéfiques alors nous
avons travaillé sur une corde de près de
dix mille jeunes avec l'institut
national de la jeunesse et de
l'éducation populaire il faut savoir que
pour les statisticiens dix mille jeunes
regards voilà deux à l'époque 145000
c'était en 2020 mission stock c'est un
très très bon un très bon échantillon on
a regardé avec les ninjas faire vraiment
un travail de fond la première grande
étude d'évaluation pour regarder
exactement qui sont ces jeunes
quelle est leur rapport à l'engagement
qu'elle est leur rapport au bénévolat et
qu'est-ce qu'ils font après donc il ya
il ya deux résultats que je trouve
encourageant même si effectivement il
montre qu'on a encore du travail
c'est que 40% des jeunes qui après le
service civique sont davantage engagés
comme bénévole qu'en entrant dans le
service civique le bémol pour être tout
à fait transparente c'est que ceux
recommandés redoublement du désir de
s'engager comme bénévole il est souvent
on le note le plus souvent chez des
jeunes qui viennent de milieux sociaux
défavorisés donc pour être très honnête
là le service civique ne ne verse pas le
déterminisme social dans le rapport de
bénévolat il permet juste de
démultiplier le désir engagement ce qui
est pour moi déjà un premier résultat
mais bon pas encore suffisant et
deuxième je trouve indicateur
intéressant c'est sur la presse service
civique très important on a 60 % des
jeunes qui trois mois ou six mois j'ai
plus après le service civique sont soit
en emploi soit ont repris une formation
ou des études alors qu' il n'avait pas
l'intention de le faire avant le service
civique et danser dans ces jeunes là qui
ont repris une formation ou des études
supérieures un tiers ont changé de
domaine et ça je trouve que c'est très
positif parce que ça confirme ce que
les jeunes nous disent de manière enfin
quand on les rencontre c'est le service
m'a permis de trouver ma voie on sait
qu'en france pourrait améliorer le
service de l'orientation et le service
civique en fait il sert aussi à ça il
sert aussi aux jeunes à vérifier si le
domaine d'activité dans lequel il avait
envie de s'engager si ces voix là si
c'est vraiment celui là oui aussi ils
veulent changer d'orientation et ça se
confirme là pour le coup de manière
scientifique dans cette étude réalisée
avec une jeep donc je pourrais bien sûr
vous vous en voyez vous envoyer le lien
sur l'international de mémoire les
chiffres déjà voilà et après donc
l'ensemble de l'outre-mer elle est
formidable non ça me gêne en tout en
consolidé sur les outre mer à l'étranger
ça c'est 2020 voilà donc on à 724 jeunes
qui sont partis à l'étranger en 2020
c'est prêt dont la moitié moins 2 par
rapport à 2019 mais bon on comprend bien
les raisons le pays principal ça je le
savais de par mes anciennes fonctions
c'est l'allemagne pour des raisons
historiques et aussi parce qu'il ya
l'office franco allemand pour la
jeunesse qui apporte des moyens
complémentaires en termes notamment de
formation les pays qui sont en tête de
l'accueil comme on dit c'est l'allemagne
maroc la tunisie et israël l'allemagne
restant toujours en tête et ensuite les
trois s'inverse selon selon les années
mais il faut savoir que en 2019 c'était
plus de 1000 jeunes à à l'envoi qui
partait et près de 500 à l'accueil
cette question de la réciprocité donc
l'accueil de jeunes en service civique
étrangers fait l'objet d'un travail
particulier à lagence skis sont formés
oui ils sont formés bien sûr au départ
avant de partir à l'international le
plus souvent bon nous on a développé des
outils d'ailleurs qu'on a on a traduit
en quatre langues fait traduire en
quatre langues pour permettre aux
organismes d'accueil sur place de bien
comprendre ce qu'est un dispositif
français le service civique c'est pas
intuitif pour un israélien un marocain
ou un an
mende savoir ce qu'est le service
civique donc on a traduit tous les
outils et puis il ya une préparation
évidemment au départ de ces jeunes là
que nous surveillons et qui est bien un
petit pris en charge par les organismes
les organismes français et des
formations aussi des organismes qui
veulent voilà rien à voir absolument
ce que j'ai répondu près j'espère vous
avez été très complet mais merci
beaucoup de la précision de deux de vos
réponses je crois que c'est la première
fois qu'on vous accueillez au sein de la
commission semblait un horaire mais le
aussi je pense que l'audition importante
parce que c'est vrai que vous l'avez
compris nous sommes très attentifs au
service civique et à sa montée en
puissance qui est un défi en l'imaginent
pour vous au quotidien et sans dénaturer
bien sûr l'esprit et
et les objectifs des d'emilie mission
confiée au jeune donc merci beaucoup
pour cette audition la présidente et la
secrétaire générale et je pense qu'on
aura d'autres occasions bien sûr de
suivre le le service civique avec avec
vous
[Musique]